DANNY KOKER: You know, when
it was a really nice car, man.
As far as I was concerned, this
was a great car to start with.
It was little bit plain,
a little bit boring.
But it's just the
right vehicle for us
to put our Count's
Kustoms vibe all over it.
And we toughened up this
ride from top to bottom now,
and she's ready for shipping.
But before she goes, I want
a little stamp of approval
from a buddy of mine, Keith.
He's over at Swing Shift Auto.
His shop does beautiful
work, so I trust his opinion.
Plus, the fact I'm
looking forward
to showing the
surprise to Kevin,
that the car is all done,
and it's actually sold.
RYAN: Oh, that's Kevin.
DANNY KOKER: Kevin Mack.
Rollin' up in the Cadillac.
The Mack-a-lack.
[laughter]
KEVIN: What up?
RYAN: Hey, the man.
- Oh my god.
Look at this thing.
[instrumental music playing]
DANNY KOKER: Dude, I wanted
you to see. '67 Camaro, clean.
To toughen up the '67
Camaro, we went old school
with a touch of modern.
For that mean look,
we added a rear deck
spoiler, a chin spoiler,
and a cowl inducted hood.
We upgraded that
small black Chevy
with some brand new headers,
a four-barrel carburetor
on top of an aluminum intake
manifold, a new distributor,
and aluminum radiator.
Underneath, we added power
steering and a power disc brake
conversion, so this baby can
turn like she's on rails,
and stop on a dime.
To top it all off, Ryan kept
that beautiful factory blue,
but added some subtle
graphics all over
to make this thing look
just a little wider
and just a little meaner.
Yeah, I got a client.
He's back east.
He needed a vehicle.
He needed it right now.
KEITH: You've been
hiding this one from me.
For a second there, I thought
he's going to keep it.
RYAN: Bro.
No, no, no, no, no.
DANNY KOKER: Let me
tell you something.
I would.
This is a car I would have in
my stable because it's very me.
I'm an old school guy.
This car has that
old school vibe.
But since it's
already been paid for
and belongs to somebody else,
I don't have much of a choice--
And you actually
made a profit on that.
I'm very, very
happy about that.
KEITH: I am happy.
DANNY KOKER: '67 Camaro.
This particular one just
takes me back to high school.
KEITH: Yeah, real
classic look to it,
but the color is stunning.
KEVIN: That is the
stock Marina Blue Poly.
KEITH: No way.
DANNY KOKER: I'm hooked on that
Cooper tires, 15 inch, 295 50s.
They do a modern
set-up now, you know,
so it's still-- it updates--
You don't have to feel like
it's ridin' on the rails.
- --the car.
- Yeah.
DANNY KOKER: And they're great.
KEVIN: Hey, could
I open the hood?
DANNY KOKER:
Absolutely, brother.
Let's check it out.
When we first got her,
she was a bone stock 327.
I mean, talking, bone stock.
Got the ceramic
coated headers on it.
It's got Flowmaster
exhaust on it.
We updated the brakes.
Got the big disk
brakes on the front--
I saw those.
DANNY KOKER: --so you get
your big booster and stuff,
and everything on it.
It goes great and
it stops great.
It's traditional.
KEVIN: [inaudible] and
it looks [inaudible]..
Wow.
It closes nice.
Just the stock interior?
This looks--
DANNY KOKER: Yeah.
KEVIN: --great.
It's a power steering car.
So this is for me, right?
[laughter]
That's why-- you
brought me over
here to give this to me, right?
[laughter]
- Yeah, man.
Yeah, man.
KEVIN: Dude, I love the
striping that you guys did.
It was real--
DANNY KOKER: That's Ryan.
It was a neutral but
beautiful color blue.
I didn't want to take
anything away from it.
Just let the color be the color.
KEVIN: Right.
Anyone who sees this thing is
just gonna absolutely love it.
DANNY KOKER: Bro, you
wanna hear this thing?
Let's do it.
[laughter]
What'd you put,
cherry bombs on it?
- Flowmaster.
- Oh.
OK.
With the Ceramacoded headers
and the Flowmaster exhaust,
it just sounds proper.
[engine revving]
DANNY KOKER: That's high school.
KEITH: Right.
That's got the
high school ride.
I would say there's no
way in hell that's a 327.
No.
Actually, one of my
favorite small-blocks is 327.
- They're bulletproof.
- Right.
They're bulletproof.
- Oh, yeah.
They're super
snappy like that.
I dig it, man.
I personally am totally
digging the car.
But Keith, if you were
the guy waiting for this,
and this got off the
truck, how would you feel?
Oh, I'd be super pleased.
I'd be happy to have it.
- Dig it.
I feel great about it.
Thanks for checking it out.
Kev.
KEVIN: Absolutely.
And this is a
great deal, Ryan.
Phenomenal.
All the boys at the shop came
out swinging on this ride, man.
Man, this car was nice
when we found her.
Plus, we had a built
in customer, so, bam!
We just got down to the fun.
We did all kinds of cool
things to this Camaro to make
her old-school-muscle-car cool.
And I gotta tell you, man,
our customer back east,
he's lucky already
paid for this thing.
'Cause if he was standing
here, I'd probably
give him his money back and
try and keep this Camaro,
'cause this baby is sweet.
It's so traditional.
I love it.
That's my style.